son nom est saffin
et qu'est-ce qu'il veut se venger
ce que je voulais vraiment de stefan était de le
rendre troublant en
se considérant comme héroïque
je suis un homme prêt à tuer la personne que tu
aimes le plus
j'ai déjà perdu tout le monde que j'ai jamais
aimé
ce qu'il veut et ce qu'il est prêt à
faire
fait de lui un personnage très effrayant à la
fois personnellement à lier mais aussi au
niveau mondial
nous éradiquons tous les deux les gens pour rendre le
monde meilleur
je veux juste être un peu plus ordonné
saffin est un adversaire redoutable
james bond doit s'adapter à ça qu'est-ce que
c'est
tu ne sais pas ce que c'est il
va tuer des millions
si on ne fait pas ça il n'y aura plus
rien à sauver
je t'ai licencié non
pas tant qu'il y en a  des gens comme vous
dans le monde
vous